foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones and A
Song of Ice and Fire update video in
this new video I will show you what Game
of Thrones actor kit Harrington had to
say during the first ever official fan
convention out in Los Angeles over the
weekend he said something that I think
most of you will find to be as
interesting as I did now before we go
any further I have to let all of you
know about this amazing new offer I'd
like to thank the sponsor of today's
video and my favorite game raid Shadow
Legends raid features a massive Universe
where you get to build up your team with
over 650 unique Champions to collect the
realm of taleria is under a shadow cast
by the dark lord cyroth in the East and
you are one of many long dead talerian
Warriors to be resurrected by taleria's
Immortal Guardian the Arbiter to stop it
rage Shadow Legends is completely free
to play and you can download it on your
mobile phone or PC raid has something
extra special happening right now
they've recently released a legendary
champion based off of MMA and pro
wrestling Legend Ronda Rousey Rhonda's
back next story is incredibly awesome
and takes some inspiration from her
background in Combat Sports born to a
minor Banner Lord house Rhonda trained
hard alongside Her Seven Brothers during
one tournament ran by her father
Rhonda's true potential as a fighter
became obvious as she took on four
nights bare-handed she quickly made her
way kicking ass and taking names until
she became Queen of the Arena you can
get Rhonda for free right now whether
you're a new or a long time player all
you've got to do is log in and play raid
for seven days between now and February
28th and Rhonda's all yours to celebrate
Rhonda's arrival and raid use the
special promo code raid Rhonda to get a
bunch of helpful stuff that's great for
leveling up your Rondo so she's at the
top of her game this month raids got a
massive new update with a ton of new
features including a brand new dungeon
and the introduction of artifact
Ascension battle through the sand
Devil's necropolis and earn precious oil
needed to take your artifacts to the
next level there are a bunch of new
holiday champion beans for those looking
to get into the festive Spirit also if
you're an Amazon Prime member you can
get your exclusive rewards and raid
right now new players use my link or
scan the QR code right here and get a
free starter pack worth almost 30
dollars a free champion virgies and also
this cool in-game loot you will find
your rewards here in your inbox for the
next 30 days only don't forget to look
for me in game under the name talking
Thrones and if you're fast you can join
my clan once again I would like to thank
raid Shadow Legends for sponsoring
today's video now for those of you who
don't know HBO and Mr Harrington are
developing a new Game of Thrones series
based on the life of Jon Snow after the
events of the original show this will be
Game of Thrones first sequel series HBO
has yet to give us their own official
announcement but as most of you already
know this information was already
confirmed by George R Martin himself the
new Jon Snow sequel series will show us
what has been happening after he was
sent north of the wall as he sat down
for the hour a long interview yesterday
at the fan convention he might have
given us a glimpse into what we might
see in the show he revealed what might
be on Jon Snow's mind after all the
events in Game of Thrones thankfully
there were a number of fans there who
was filming everything that was said now
I want to show you some of the standout
moments from his interview in this first
video I want to show you what he said
that I think reveals why he actually
wants to go back to Game of Thrones as
Jon Snow After Game of Thrones ended
many of us thought we may never see him
as Jon Snow again after all he was
working on this show for over a decade
so most of us would understand why he
would want to walk away however with
that being said I think he sort of
reveals why he wants to step back in as
Jon Snow again
um but amazing like what better way to
spay your 20s than in a show like this
and I had a lot of fun
um
but I think that what it's what it's
meant is that you look for that thing
your whole career as an actor I think
you look for that thing that one thing
that just goes big or that you're known
for
if you have it in your 20s you're left
going
[ __ ] what now
what do I do now I did the thing
now this is only my assumption but I
think there is this void that he wants
to fill in his life now that he's been
away from the show for over three years
he's most likely realizing how much he
misses working on the most successful
show ever made it must also be a little
intoxicating when you're walking around
as one of the most recognizable faces
everywhere you go not to mention he may
not have liked how Jon Snow's story
ended either now that him and his
friends are writing the show he can have
a major influence over what happens to
Jon Snow in his version of the ending I
believe this does shed some light on why
we may see Jon Snow again and as I've
said before I will be right here for all
of it okay now in this next video you
will actually see him answer something
regarding what Jon Snow's life must be
like now after Game of Thrones has ended
as well as the Jon Snow sequel series
itself it gives us a little insight into
what might be on Jon Snow's mind now
that he's living his life in Exile away
from everyone he loves
that my question was going to be in
light of
um and enlightened on the fact that a
possible show about Jon Snow is coming
[Applause]
up
again
[Applause]
yeah I hope so
I hope that would be you know the funny
thing about
said this earlier as well but I was
thinking about John and his choice of
women which is
the
I think he's like his maternal
the Eternal figure he can have with
Caitlyn
who hated him and treated him like I I
swear I'm sorry I treat treated him like
crap right and
tends to go for really dominant women
it's quite interesting isn't it he goes
for the reader and I think that there's
some Freudian thing going on
um with that in mind I think he would he
would go for a Sim you know but I I
think that the especially the Egret
thing burned him so much
that he is definite PTSD and Trauma
about
being in a relationship
so I think it would be it would be tough
yeah
so as you can see when the fan asked him
if Jon Snow will ever love again he
wanted to say yes in fact he almost did
but then he stopped himself and said I
hope so then he also reveals that it
might be hard for Jon to ever be in
another relationship again because of
all the heartbreaking and loss he has
suffered over the years we just might
see Jon think about and discuss these
very things in the new show now later in
the same interview he gives us even more
insight into what Jon Snow's State of
Mind might be like after the finale
um my question is the fact that your
character Jon Snow he goes through such
a progression throughout the seasons
he's a ward um he goes to war so many
things happen to him
um he he finds out that he is you know
he's a Targaryen and then he
unfortunately has to kill Danny and then
he goes you know they throw him in jail
and then he ends up back on the wall do
you ever think that Jennifer like your
character may have been cheated he kind
of goes back to who you know the war
isn't exactly the most comfying place on
um
I think he I think if you asked him
he said he would have felt he got off
lightly
he you know at the end of the show when
we find him in that cell
he's preparing to be beheaded
and he wants to be he's done like
the fact he goes to the wall is the
greatest gift to him
and also the great curse
he's going to go back up to the place
with all this history
and live out his life thinking about how
he killed Danny
and live out his life thinking about
Egret dying his
and live out his life thinking about how
he hung Ollie
and live out his life thinking about all
of this trauma
and that
that's interesting
so I think that the
when we leave them at the end of the
show
there's always this feeling of like
I think we wanted some kind of little
smile things are okay he's not okay
he's not okay
yeah
he said now that Jon Snow is in Exile
out Beyond the Wall he may spend the
rest of his life thinking about the
death of Danny egret and even Ollie as
you all know the death of all three of
them did affect him greatly and we may
see how this is affecting him and his
life After Game of Thrones while giving
this answer he even said this is
interesting which I think reveals the
fact that he has been thinking about
this himself most likely while him and
his friends are in the writer's room
making the Jon Snow show it seems like
all of this lossy and heartbreak is
something he will want to explore in the
new show and that certainly does make a
lot of sense he said that Jon is not
okay so maybe that will lead him to
wanting to do some more good in the
realm while he's still alive this might
be the one thing that motivates him to
go south again to stand up against any
new enemies who might want to do harm to
his family or loved ones or Westeros in
general I did watch the entire interview
and although he never outright address
the Jon Snow sequel series I do believe
some of his answers shine a light on
what he has been thinking of about in
regards to the show and what Jon Snow's
life might look like now then again
maybe I'm looking for things that aren't
actually there because I really want
this show to get made let me know what
you think about what he said as always
I'll let you know if I find out any new
information regarding any of the Game of
Thrones shows or George RR Martin's
novels I want to thank all of you for
watching the video I hope everyone has a
great day I will see you again very soon
bye
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you